"She-Hulk: Attorney at Law" has an amazing
lead, the return of Professor Hulk, and some
surprising MCU connections.
So what do you need to know before the big
premiere?
Keep watching to find out.
At the D23 presentation in 2019, "Ms. Marvel,"
"Moon Knight," and "She-Hulk" were all announced
as upcoming series for Disney+ and Marvel
Studios.
Almost three years later to the day, "She-Hulk:
Attorney at Law" is scheduled to drop on the
streamer on August 17, 2022.
The series will follow the same format as
"WandaVision," running for a total of nine
shorter episodes as opposed to the MCU's other
shows with six one-hour-ish episodes.
New episodes will drop at 3 a.m.
Eastern on Disney+ every Wednesday.
If "She-Hulk: Attorney at Law" follows the
once-per-week format, the series will conclude
with its finale on October 12.
This puts the new show smack dab in the middle
of the release dates for "Thor: Love and Thunder"
and "Black Panther: Wakanda Forever."
Joining the MCU in "She-Hulk: Attorney at
Law" is "Orphan Black" star Tatiana Maslany
as Jennifer Walters, aka She-Hulk.
In December 2020, Marvel Studios revealed
the casting news on social media after Maslany
denied her involvement just two months prior.
The new series marks the first live-action
project for Maslany since her stint on HBO's
"Perry Mason" in 2020.
Maslany spoke a little about her upcoming
role in "She-Hulk" while chatting with Empire
magazine.
The Canadian actress said part of her inspiration
for playing Jennifer came from the late Scottish
musician SOPHIE.
She told Empire,
"What I love about SOPHIE's music is this
combo of organic and electrical, industrial-type
sounds that felt connected to She-Hulk."
When it comes to her character, the actress
called her story "the antithesis of most superhero
narratives," suggesting we're about to get
a whole new take on MCU heroes.
The second original Avenger getting some time
in an MCU Disney+ series is Mark Ruffalo,
returning to the role of Bruce Banner after
his appearance in the post-credits of "Shang-Chi
and the Legend of the Ten Rings."
Ruffalo's last major MCU role was in "Avengers:
Endgame," and it looks like "She-Hulk: Attorney
at Law" might be his final performance with
the studio.
Based on comments he made to Access Hollywood
at the "Adam Project" premiere, it's being
speculated that Ruffalo will retire from the
MCU.
He had high praise for Maslany:
"Frickin' legendary as the She-Hulk.
I'm passing the 'banner' onto her."
Based on what we see in the trailer for "She-Hulk,"
he'll serve as something of a Hulk coach to
Jennifer Walters while she acclimates to her
newfound powers.
After almost a year of rumors, "The Good Place"
actress Jameela Jamil confirmed she was joining
the MCU in "She-Hulk: Attorney at Law" in
her debut TikTok post.
Jamil will play Titania , aka Mary MacPherran,
a longtime rival of She-Hulk.
The comic book version of Mary gains her powers
from Doctor Doom after she is swept away into
Battleworld.
She wields superhuman strength and is an expert
in hand-to-hand combat.
She's quite the match for She-Hulk, but normally
finds herself the loser in their many battles.
Since "The Good Place" concluded in 2020,
Jamil has been more selective about the projects
she takes on.
Jamil told Hollywood Life,
"I always want what I do to try and align
or embolden my social justice work.
I feel like that is something that we are
achieving with this show — we're saying
something important.
We're doing something important, we're pushing
the boundaries."
When a new MCU project is on the horizon,
a frenzy begins online as fans try to figure
out if there will be any cameos.
"She-Hulk: Attorney at Law" is no different.
Only this time around, two cameos have already
been confirmed by Marvel Studios and Disney.
After appearing in 2021's "Shang-Chi and the
Legend of the Ten Rings" for a brief fight
scene, Abomination will return for "She-Hulk."
This time, we'll get to see him in his human
form, and Emil Blonsky, played by Tim Roth,
even makes an appearance in the trailer.
He's locked in a special cell, so we know
he's still not to be trusted 14 years after
his MCU introduction.
"How do you feel?"
"Pissed off and ready for round three."
Also joining "She-Hulk: Attorney at Law" is
Wong, played by Benedict Wong, fresh off his
recent appearance in "Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness."
We haven't seen Wong yet in a trailer for
the show, but since he was the sorcerer fighting
Abomination in "Shang-Chi and the Legend of
the Ten Rings," it makes sense that he would
show up.
There are plenty of other rumors suggesting
characters from all across the MCU will cameo,
from Liv Tyler's return as Betty Ross to Krysten
Ritter reprising her role as Jessica Jones,
but these should be taken with a grain of
salt.
The first official trailer for "She-Hulk:
Attorney at Law" shocked the MCU fandom by
giving them a brief glimpse of Frog-Man.
A popular Twitter spoiler account had previously
leaked the character's inclusion in the series,
but it wasn't taken too seriously at the time.
No actor has been connected to Frog-Man, but
with Josh Segarra and Griffin Matthews attached
to unknown characters, it's reasonably safe
to assume one of them is playing the obscure
character.
Not to be confused with his dad, the villainous
Leap-Frog, Frog-Man first appeared in 1982's
"Marvel Team-Up #121."
When Leap-Frog, real name Vincent Patilio,
gets arrested and put away, his son Eugene
decides to use the mantle as a force for good
under the modified identity of Frog-Man.
There is no substantial direct connection
between Jennifer Walters and Eugene in the
comics.
However, Leap-Frog's criminal endeavors frequently
pit him against Daredevil, and Matt Murdock
just so happens to be a lawyer who recently
made his post-Netflix MCU debut in "Spider-Man:
No Way Home," so that connection could explain
his appearance.
According to the official synopsis from Disney+,
"She-Hulk: Attorney at Law" will focus on
Jennifer Walters, an attorney working at a
firm that deals with superhuman clients.
Jennifer will also navigate a complicated
love life, which is depicted in the first
trailer for the series.
As she searches for dates, Jennifer will be
in her Hulk form, as it looks like the world
has already accepted her new look.
As previously mentioned, Mark Ruffalo's Hulk
will teach Jennifer how to handle her new
6-foot-7-inch form and superhuman strength.
Everything looks fresh for Jennifer in "She-Hulk,"
as she is taking on a new job, new physique,
and new romantic interests all at the same
time.
Not to mention her first opponent in Titania.
There's a brief moment in the trailer where
the two women battle it out in a courtroom,
but the root of their issues in this particular
series is still in the air.
Much as the Hawkeye mantle was passed on to
Kate Bishop in "Hawkeye," we expect the same
sort of thing to happen in "She-Hulk," with
Maslany being the MCU's primary green giant
moving forward.
"Yes!
Yes!
No!
NO!"
We all know by now how Bruce Banner gets his
powers, but the origin of She-Hulk's powers
is a little more obscure, simply because the
character has spent comparatively little time
in mainstream media.
Unless you are a Marvel Comics reader, you
might be totally unaware of how Jennifer bulks
up.
Based on what we see in the trailer, we expect
to see Jennifer get her powers early in the
series.
It would be a surprise to find out she already
has them by the time the show begins, although
that's not impossible.
Here's how it goes down: Jennifer is shot
by a man named Nicholas Trask who is seeking
revenge against her father.
Her wounds are grave, and she needs a blood
transfusion, so her cousin Bruce steps up
to help her out when there are no other options.
With gamma radiation coursing through his
veins, there was no way to avoid Jennifer
getting the irradiated blood into her system.
But it's not just Bruce's blood that turns
her; it's her anger and fear that really does
the trick.
"Those are like the baseline of any woman,
like, existing."
And just like that, she becomes superhuman.
Jennifer is not quite as powerful as Bruce
in her Hulk form, and her stature is slightly
smaller, which makes her look more humanlike
and less monster-like.
As with the three most recent Marvel Studios/Disney+
series, "She-Hulk: Attorney at Law" will have
more than one director.
"She-Hulk" will be split between Kat Coiro
and Anu Valia.
Coiro has directed episodes of popular projects
like "Dead to Me" and "It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia," while Valia is known for her
work on "A.P. Bio" and the "Sex and the City"
revival series "And Just Like That..."
Coiro pushed hard to get the job, telling
Collider,
"I'm a huge fan of the MCU, and I was actually
a giant fan of the She-Hulk comics, so when
I heard they were making it, I went full court
press and really sold myself as the person
to bring this story to life.
It was a huge and involved process."
In an Instagram post from December 2020, Valia
revealed Coiro is taking the lead on "She-Hulk:
Attorney at Law," writing,
"friggin stoked to go on this ride together
([Coiro] is our visionary leader im just doing
a few eppys !! but it'll be a fun one)."
The Hollywood Reporter revealed that Jessica
Gao was hired as head writer for "She-Hulk:
Attorney at Law" back in November 2019.
Gao is an Emmy-winning writer who nabbed the
gold statue for her work on the "Rick and
Morty" episode "Pickle Rick."
She also has writing credits on "Robot Chicken,"
"Big Time Rush," and "Silicon Valley," just
to name a few.
Gao was absolutely flabbergasted to get the
job on "She-Hulk," and shared her excitement
in an Instagram post after the big news was
announced.
She wrote,
"DREAM COME TRUE.
I AM DECEASED.
(Don't worry, I will resurrect to do the job.)"
Subsequent social media posts of Gao's regarding
the new Disney+ series have only mirrored
her initial excitement.
She shared casting news to her feed, and when
the first trailer was released, Gao also told
the world on Instagram that she couldn't wait
for everyone to see Maslany in the role.
We know for certain that "She-Hulk: Attorney
at Law" connects to "Shang-Chi and the Legend
of Ten Rings" in a minor way with a blink-and-you'll
miss it confirmation in the trailer.
When we see Wong leaving the fight club in
the Phase 4 film, he opens a portal, and on
the other side is a room with a large cell
in the middle of it.
The same cell can be seen in the "She-Hulk"
trailer, where Jennifer Walters talks to an
imprisoned Emil Blonsky.
As far as future projects, it's possible we'll
see "She-Hulk" connect to the "Thunderbolts"
movie recently declared as in-development.
Some fans think Emil is being held in The
Cube — a SHIELD prison that houses various
super-powered criminals, occasionally of the
gamma-irradiated variety.
All we're saying is if Valentina Allegra de
Fontaine needs someone to join a team already
consisting of John Walker and Yelena Belova,
she could probably swing by The Cube and offer
Emil a deal without much trouble.
Fans weren't too happy with the quality of
the CGI in the first "She-Hulk: Attorney at
Law" trailer, but that's not the only controversy
surrounding the series.
A few sources have come forward to say there
were some problems behind the scenes.
Former Variety and Collider writer Jeff Sneider
revealed in March 2022 on his "The Hot Mic
with Jeff and John" podcast, that he's heard
about issues with "She-Hulk," claiming,
"I've heard not good things behind the scenes
... and I've asked whether it's 'Moon Knight'
or 'Ms. Marvel' or 'Secret Invasion' or any
of these [projects], they are always like,
'She-Hulk is the one that could be a problem."
Former Hollywood Reporter editor Matthew Belloni
mentioned in his website's newsletter in May
2022 that the newest Disney+ series are being
watched carefully, writing,
"The upcoming 'She-Hulk' is supposedly a mess,
I've heard (even with Mark Ruffalo in a small
role), and 'Ms. Marvel' is another big test
for fans.
Nobody's saying Marvel's TV output is in trouble,
but it's something to keep an eye on."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.